public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
julien dray est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir et merci donc d'être
présent à ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec l afp avec les échos et radio
classique dans cinq jours les électeurs
de gauche sont tant qu'appelé à désigner
leur candidat à la présidentielle
premier tour de la primaire ce sera bien
sûr le sujet principal de cette émission
je viendrai au cours de laquelle souvent
du temps vous en doutiez au cours de
laquelle vous allez répondre à trois
grandes questions celle de jean francis
pécresse quel est l'état d'esprit de
françois hollande vous êtes un de ses
proches vous nous direz quel est donc
son état d'esprit vous nous aiderez
également sans doute à à décoder le chef
de l'état par exemple sa présence au
théâtre le soir du deuxième débat
deuxième question le rassemblement
peut-il se faire sur des programmes
aussi divergents en d'autres termes les
sept candidats sont-ils réconciliables
vous le dirai à stéphanie le rouge enfin
pris en tenaille on le voit bien par
deux hommes qui ont le vent en poupe
jean luc mélenchon et emmanuel macron le
ps at il en fait c'est s'est d'ores et
déjà d'être l'avenir de la gauche
vous répondrez à mickaël szames s mais
d'abord une question d'actualité
est ce que vous connaissez votre bureau
de vote pour dimanche
non je dois voter en essonne est ce que
vous connaissez votre bulletin de vote
oui je connais a priori je connais pas
ce que j'attends pas la dernière minute
et je vais
dit dès le départ que j'avais un une
tristesse parce que françois hollande
n'était pas là et puis après dans la
dans le dans la manière dont les choses
s'étaient passées j'avais une amitié et
une convergence idéologique ayant plus
qu'une amitié parce que j'ai pas de
détestation à l'égard des autres
candidats mais candidate mais que je
ressentais plus dense que représentait
vincent peillon que pour le reste bon
des autres candidats voilà donc je ré
semblablement par une nomination
dernières minutes mais elle ne croit pas
à votre choix n'est pas encore fermé des
fonds était génial c'était une austin
fond
boutaty filipo bernad d'illumination
parce que vous êtes en manque peut-être
de réversion l'aurait fait débat non je
suis pas en manque de révélations je
pense que quand on s'est investi comme
je m'étais investi ces derniers mois
pour permettre au président de la
république françois hollande des deux
candidats on a forcément un peu de
nostalgie ou d'un colis bon au début je
regardais ça un peu avec distance et
j'ai du mal à m'imprégner de ce débat
parce qu'il y avait tout ce que
représentaient les mois passés bon et
maintenant je regarde et il faut se
tourner vers l'avenir vous êtes vous
l'avez trouvé convaincant vincent
peillon l'homme qui venait de only
prévint oui mais s'il l'a fait c'est
aussi parce que bon ticket montréal ai
parlé juste un peu avant ce qu'ils
considéraient que ce qu'il représentait
en tous les cas ce que représentait
cette mouvance n'étaient pas représentés
comme il le fallait
d'un mandat d'arrêt ni le soutien du
gouvernement le socialisme de
gouvernance au sein du gouvernement au
sens de du réformisme radical au sens
non pas de la facilité mais au sens de
la complexité de ce que représente ce
cheminot gouvernement c'est à dire cette
volonté de transformation tout en
gardant les bacs est prêt à vous suivre
vous parlez de vos deux potes souffrance
effectivement après le renoncement mais
530 est ce que c'est une souffrance quai
qui n'est pas que politique et amical
passe bien sûr c'est un long
compagnonnage longue amitié d eau avec
des bases très élevées mais j'aurais et
j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse aller ou
qu'ils puissent aller puisque mois
jusqu'au qu'un cautère parce que je
pense que l'épreuve démocratique c'est
aussi défendre semble que dans son bilan
je suis pas convaincu que bon les choses
auraient été si noir et que peut-être
abandonné il ya cru le penser on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir
mais pour vous vincent peillon est
l'héritier aujourd'hui 2
françois hollande jean héritier je pense
son digne successeur je pense que c'est
pas comme ça qu'il est le plus dans la
logique de la succession il est dans
cette logique de ce que représente ce
que j'ai appelé le socialisme le
gouvernement mais par rapport à françois
hollande mais manuel valls aussi mais à
jeudi un magret mais je pense pas qu'il
d'héritier il n'y a pas d'héritier
françois hollande d'ailleurs l'a dit ne
prendra pas parti en tous les cas dans
cette première partie des primaires bon
voilà c'est pas et je pense que le débat
n'est pas de savoir si hollande va
soutenir l'un ou l'autre
et d'ailleurs je pense que pour les uns
et pour les autres c'est pas forcément
la chose qu'il faut faire mais est-ce
que vous avez joué un rôle dans la
décision de vincent peillon de se porter
candidat j'avais joué un rôle en
coulisses est ce que vous l'avez
encourager prochain que je vais skier
votre créature
non non non c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
je lui ai demandé de ne pas figurer dans
aucun organigramme parce que je voulais
pas qu'on laisse qu'on puisse développer
ce que je voyais bien et qui était pas
bien d'ailleurs pour lui l'idée qu' il
était le candidat de substitution
substitué par un vrai joué aucun rôle et
ce avant cette annonce surprise de sa
candidature je ne joue pas beaucoup de
rôles dans ses campagnes on vous l'avez
vu je me suis un peu tenu à l'écart je
fais pas les maths il a le matin pour
aller guerroyer
et pour revenir sur publiquement avec
nous merci on poursuit l'émission avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
il nous rejoint
bonsoir jean francis on sur michel
bonsoir julien dray vous êtes proche
évidemment de françois hollande
dans quel état d'esprit et il est ce
qu'il n'ya pas cette forme de deux
regrets oui je souris parce que quand
françois hollande a employé cette
expression au mois de mai
ça va mieux on verra tout le monde est
tombé dessus défendu je vais justifié
puis vous écoutez je me disais bon c'est
dommage qu'il ait pas parlé comme ça il
ya trois-quatre mois on disait pas on
faisait ça va mieux j'avais d'ailleurs
fait de la pédagogie en dix ans le terme
ça va mieux peut pas dire ça va bien
c'est à dire que les choses sont en
train de s'améliorer
voilà bon maintenant la parenthèse est
fini il ya eu un emballement je crois
une comportement d'ailleurs qu'il faudra
un jour ou l'autre
analyser le rapport que la presse a eu
avec françois hollande et peut-être
aussi des erreurs à ya beaucoup de
choses à dire sur les rapports de
françois hollande est un rapport ciotti
yeux de françois est bon aussi des
erreurs qui ont été commises au début ou
des manque d'explications ou peut-être
trop d'explications qu'à tuer
l'explication autant des cas trop
d'explications of par rapport à vos
explications homme bon il ya
certainement des choses à voir
maintenant est ce qu a la nostalgie ce
serait malhonnête de ma part de vous
dire que non oui la jsk du regret
certainement parce qu'il ya là une force
et une énergie qui encore la chefferie
ces chiffres sont là et c'est qu'on
travaille avec lui maintenant il n'y a
pas de remise en cause de sa décision
il vous en parle vous le voyez pas un
but pins où vous parlez je veux pas
m'arrêter de parler parce qu'il n'est
pas prévu de lui parler parce qu'il est
plus candidat à la présidentielle je
parlais avant qu'elle le soit je parle
et quand il était président j'espère lui
parler encore longtemps après et de
parler politique et pas simplement du
temps qui passe
parce que sur nous c'est un combat c'est
pareil on l'a on a en a pas on s'est
engagé en politique simplement parce que
ça nous plaisait pour faire une carrière
professionnelle et puis partir après la
retraite
c'est un combat cdi des cetc j'ai une
énergie qu'on met au service de ses
idées jusqu'au bout jusqu au dernier
train de vie qui voudraient vous avez le
sentiment qu'il a fait une erreur en
renonçant l'erreur je peux pas le juger
comme cela je peux pas employer ce mot
là pourquoi parce que c'est lui qui
décide
moi je suis pas candidat
j'étais je peux pas me substituer à lui
il ya dans cette élection il ya la fois
le contexte vous allez essayer de peser
quand vous avez dit il avait une erreur
non j'ai pas je peux pas parler comme ça
parce que leno considéré qu'il pouvait
contrairement à ce que certains me
disaient s'engager dans cette campagne
sans avoir l'inquiétude absolue d'une
élimination rapide parce que je
considérais qu'il y avait des choses à
dire qu'ils avaient des choses à
expliquer et qu'il y avait aussi des
choses a réexpliqué est donc à prendre
une nouvelle dimension
lui il a considéré que que non il a
considéré que non regard de ce qu'il a
analysé l'éclatement de la gauche sa
dispersion
la forme des primaires telles qu'elles
étaient en train de s'installer et qui
prenait la forme d'une sorte de
référendum anti françois hollande
donc il a considéré qu' il n'avait pas
de la marge de manoeuvre qui lui
permettait de pouvoir s'exprimer
correctement ou 2 se veut dire eh bien
avec le pays il a été d'une certaine
manière poussée aussi dans cette
décision
donc oui il ya un contexte qui s'est
installé luis a secret lorsqu'il voit
aujourd'hui cette campagne primaire à
gauche et ce qu'il a ce sentiment que ba
il aurait pu faire mieux qu il aurait dû
y aller est ce qu'il a le sentiment que
quelqu'un porte un véritable projet de
gauche un projet pour habitude de ne pas
parler à sa place et je ne le ferai pas
aujourd'hui puisque je ne les fais hier
donc je pense que dans l'est dans les
semaines et mois à venir il donnera
certainement dû manière ou d'une autre
son sentiment mais je le connais assez
et on partage à cette chose ensemble
qui des fois on est vraiment des accords
pour avoir le sentiment d'après moi qui
a eu beaucoup de gâchis et qu' on aurait
pu s'éviter
je regardais s'il voulait le débat
dimanche et je regardais la tonalité
finalement apaisée à l'égard du
président de la république à l'égard
même du bilan et je me dis mais pourquoi
ce tour n'a pas été utilisé pendant les
cinq ans qui viennent de s'écouler
pourquoi on était toujours dans le bruit
et la fureur salvagnac et pas des choses
à dire ça veut dire qu'elle ait pas des
choses à critiquer nous on est monté
jusqu'à on est monté jusqu'au paroxysme
dans cette dénonciation d'un vu des
choses qui pour moi un parlementaire
quand même un peu expérimentés j'avais
jamais vu j'ai découvert les
parlementaires ces risques étaient prêts
à voter des motions de censure contre un
gouvernement sauf d'ailleurs il ne se
passe rien derrière
bon pourquoi tout cela parce que je
pense que mon sentiment c'est que je
pense qu'on a laissé s'installer un
climat peut-être pas par faiblesse parce
que l'idée c'est que les choses peut
être aller aller mieux
et puis que par rapport à ça aussi il ya
toute une génération qui est extrêmement
pressés et qui a manqué du sens de
l'histoire et du sens de la
responsabilité et qui sait plus
comporter comme une génération des
congrès du parti socialiste comme
génération défendant l'intérêt général
des manuels valls il est dans cette
génération encore non parce que depuis
il a essayé d il a affronté cette
génération y a bon après est ce que dans
dans dans le final il n'a pas participé
ça serait difficile de dire que
l'interview 'journal du dimanche' m'a
laissé un bon souvenir
le fameux interview il a annoncé qu'il
était prêt à être candidat contre ouvrir
la république vous allez voter donc on
l'a compris vincent peillon dimanche
dans cette décision est ce qu'il ya une
analyse purement politique ou est ce
qu'il ya des restrictions une dimension
personnelle en gros pour faire clair
vous en voulez à man down
j'ai autant aucun antagonisme moi j'ai
aucun antagonisme que par ailleurs je
pense que je lui ai toujours dit que
manuel valls était d'abord que dont je
connais depuis très longtemps et de
grande valeur
même si les accords est cuit là le bleu
le problème c'est qu'avec vincent
peillon je me plais beaucoup de
batailles politiques communes à
l'intérieur du parti
disons qu'on a une histoire commune tout
se souvient de ce que j'avais créé avec
lui en 2002 on appelait nouveau parti
socialiste on a été ensemble dans la
campagne de ségolène royal
bon et donc il ya une continuité moi je
me retrouve dans plusieurs éléments qui
met en avant et qui ce qui me qui
m'intéresse la question la gestion de la
crise européenne équipe de ce point de
vue là d'ailleurs il est une forme de
différenciation etc ce qui a été fait
auquel moi je tapais berges pour s'est
effectivement que le couple franco
allemand
le moteur la construction européenne et
qu'il faut lui donner une nouvelle
dimension et je ne suis pas dans une
logique d'affrontement avec l'allemagne
de madame merkel loin de là et je pense
d'ailleurs que ce qui est en train de se
passer avec monsieur 30 montre qu' il ya
quelque chose à reconstruire de très
fort et qui peut sortir l'europe de
l'impasse je suis d'accord avec sa trame
budgétaire tel qu'il a définie c'est à
dire pas dépenser de l'argent n'importe
comment sais tu ce qui est un acquis
pour nous qui aurait dû être un acquis
qui ce que j'appelle le social le
gouvernement faire ce que je dis et dire
ce que je fais est donc pas promettre
des choses qu'on est incapable de tenir
par la suite parce qu'on est dans des
dépenses budgétaires
aucun sens bon donc il a il a fixé ses
ya un vrai travail sérieux qui est fait
j'étais même pour étonner agréablement
surpris par la manière dont ils
s'éviteraient approprié l'ensemble de
ses conseils merci beaucoup jean francis
pécresse au dessus et la deuxième partie
de l'épreuve de vérité avec stéphanie le
rouge de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint
l'épreuve de vérité avec afp bonsoir
stéphanie la question qu'on se pose
c'est est-ce que ces sept candidats qui
ont des programmes si différent par
exemple sur la loi travail sur le
cannabis ce qu'ils vont pouvoir se
réconcilier
à la fin de cette première question du
cannabis de côté parce que c'est comme
pas la question essentielle mais on
ad'autres un bon et puis le d'énergie à
un bon ça c'est la question des réfugiés
par exemple ça fait partie des débats
qui ont lieu dans l'annoncé d'accords le
revenu universel
alors après il ya non moi je pense pas
que soient inconciliables après il ya
des approches différentes
il ya des dix filles et des approches
différentes il ya des conceptions de
l'action de la gauche différentes qui
sont en train de se de s'affronter mais
ça c c'est l'histoire du parti
socialiste c'est pas nouveau il n'y a
pas on découvre pas une divergence
telles qu'elles soient insurmontables
d'ailleurs le débat de dimanche
plus que d'après moi le premier débat a
montré qu'ils avaient aussi des éléments
de convergence et que bon ben voilà
c'est la famille socialiste elle a
toujours été source de débats et de
débats qui est parfois été tendues entre
entre
françois mitterrand et michel rocard
entre françois mitterrand et les
communistes ou même les débats que moi
même je mené avec jean luc mélenchon à
l'époque aux affaires la gauche
socialiste contraint certains une
certaine dérive sociale libérale ce qui
est de nouveau pendant ce quinquennat ça
a été ce qu'on appelait la fronde
on a eu
voilà ce mouvement de parlementaires qui
se sont opposés à peu près
systématiquement à la politique du
gouvernement vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure on a deux des candidats qui sont
des anciens ministres qui sont partis
sur des désaccords politiques lourds
donc on peut quand même légitimement se
demander s'ils vont réussir à se mettre
d'accord après sept tentes déchirées et
la question à l'heure sera posée à eux
c'est à dire de savoir quelle est la
responsable qui vit et qui prendront si
le candidat qui désignait n'est pas à
l'image de leurs idées ça et d'ailleurs
normalement ils ont signé une charte en
disant qu'ils soutiendront celui qui est
désigné quel qu'il soit bon on verra
bien alors parmi les différences que
vous évoquez effectivement stéphanie il
y avait la question des réfugiés une
passe d'armes votre soir sur ce thème là
entre manuel valls et vincent peillon
manuel valls eux qui affiche sa fierté
et son honneur également on les écoute
vale a c'est que ici comme ailleurs on
met toujours en cause la france sans la
france le mali aurait été déstabilisé
nous aurons connu une crise migratoire
la france est à l'initiative même si
c'est difficile sur la question syrienne
et enfin c'est l'honneur de la france
d'avoir tenu cette politique il faut
être clair ici où on ouvre les
frontières on est capable de les
maîtriser
d'abord je voudrais dire à manuel valls
avec l'amitié et le respect que j'ai
pour lui que quand on critique des
discours qui sont les siens ou même des
politiques qu'il a menées en
responsabilité on ne critique pas la
france aux critiques
une politique qui a été menée au nom de
la france ce n'est pas la même chose et
ça rendra le débat plus facile entre
nous factuellement s'élance en payant
qui a raison avec tout le respect qu'on
a sur la personnalité de daniel wass il
peut pas dire qu incarne la france
et puis un point c'est tout et il dit
chacun une politique que j'ai pratiqué
que j'ai mise en place en france et on
peut être en désaccord avec cette
politique pour les parents
quand on est en désaccord et ses
politiques on dépend des accords avec la
france seraient point là est-ce que
effectivement vincent peillon avait
encore raison quand il disait qu'il y
avait eu un désaccord entre
le premier ministre et le chef de l'état
françois hollande bon alors il faut pas
rentrer a essayé de rentrer dans les
subtilités mais c'est vrai que la
réalité est un point important c'est
vrai il faut les connaître que la
manière dont manuel valls étaient
adressées en allemagne à la chancelière
n'était pas le ton sur lequel le
président de la république s'adressait
lui à la chancelière et la nature des
relations qu'ils ont été construits et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya une
différence qu'un hiver gens ce que j'ai
pu pointer tout à l'heure et pour moi
les très importants cette différence je
pense que la relance de la construction
européenne passera par
l'approfondissement des relations franco
allemandes et qu'il faut en finir avec
une sorte de de détende à français qui
considèrent qu'il ya une forme de
supériorité par rapport aux allemands je
pense qu'on est dans une nouvelle phase
qu'on doit aller beaucoup plus loin dans
l'intégration d'un certain nombre de
politiques communes et je pense que
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui n'a pas été assez approfondi par
françois hollande parce que il a
reconstruit la relation franco allemande
sur des bases vraiment très saine
on voit bien par rapport à ce qu'avait
été la politique suivie par nicolas
sarkozy a un profond respect de la
chancelière à l'égard de françois
hollande
et je pense qu'on a pu aller plus loin
il manque une feuille de route franco
allemand très volontaire sur la
construction européenne
et c'est l'enjeu de cette présidentielle
manuel valls a fait des efforts pour
incarner le rassemblement il a infléchi
un peu sa ligne il a fait cette volte
face assez inattendu sur le 49-3 par
exemple est-ce que vous êtes convaincus
par ces efforts de manuel valls pour
incarner justement peut-être le point
central
je pense qu'il fait effectivement des
efforts jeunes occasion je me pose c'est
que c'est arrive c'est ça pose un
problème de crédibilité parce qu'on voit
bien que sur la question du 49 3 il ya
une grosse interrogation il en est
pourquoi tout d'un coup il le remet en
cause alors que lille a utilisé et qu'on
aurait pu faire autrement quand même les
olivier faure à le président du groupe
socialiste a fait remarquer qu'un
amendement était possible qui aurait
permis d'éviter l'utilisation du
calendrier le socialisme de gouvernement
- car il incarne en partie que d'être
plus que vincent peillon puisqu'il a
l'expérience avec nous oui mais ceci dit
au gouvernement ce pas simplement
expérience que l'on d'expérience ça peut
être aussi la fatalité j'ai connu ça moi
quand j'étais combat 2d battant plus
exactement l'intérieur du parti ali sont
mises et l'expérience paix ans
d'expérience à venir aussi une forme de
fatalité ou on admettait qu'on pouvait
rien faire moi je n'admets pas qu'on
peut rien faire
voilà donc il ya il faut concilier cette
réalité et cette volonté
voilà et donc il ya un équilibre
toujours à trouver quand on ne fait que
de la règle croyez-vous toujours cette
volonté
vous n'avez pas parlé dano d'arnaud
montebourg
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa
candidature s'est affichée notamment ce
matin avec j'avais fait bien concentrés
en creux tout à l'heure en disant qu'il
fallait un candidat capable de restaurer
la relation entre razr berlin j'ai un
désaccord clé avec eux arnaud montebourg
arnaud montebourg revisite les positions
de jean pierre chevènement qui ont
toujours été respectable mais quelle moi
j'ai toujours été en désaccord
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à travailler plus que on regarde
un regard amical à une ambiance sonore y
avait un désaccord sur cette question là
voilà et c'est un désaccord évident
effectivement qui est fondamental voilà
c'est qu'ils renvoient à l'idée par
exemple que quand on a gagné en mille
ans en 2012
on pouvait simplement arriver et dire
aux allemands bon maintenant on est la
france donc vous obéissez tout le monde
savait que ça ne pouvait tout le monde a
vu que ça ne peut pas se passer comme ça
voilà on est pas convaincu par son
projet de créer une forme de minorité de
blocage des pays du sud
ça marche pas au rapport de force et
ceux qui s'engagent là dessus en général
sont vite devant l'échec
l'europe ça peu de marche et que parce
qu'il ya un socle très fort et ce socle
c'est le soin de franco allemand il ya
des candidats qui vous inquiète
franchement la primaire eelv où certains
mouvements peur non moi je ne plonge pas
dans la peur je suis dans la rivale en
mer non mais c'est pas parce que vous
êtes en désaccord idéologique avec des
gens qui vous font peur il ya des piles
côté sympathie mais je me dis je ne me
retrouve pas dans un certain nombre de
positions je lui dis je en prendre une
autre et qu'il aille vraiment j'ai un
désaccord total c'est cette histoire de
49,3 citoyens d'après moi même eu à ce
jour qui est pas moi d'après moi
ubuesque voilà parce que si on applique
la histoire du 40 nations il ce truc se
met en place mais c'est un gouvernable
et donc vous souhaitez emmanuel macron
simon ghana non non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
il ya un travail je vous ai donné la
feuille de route la feuille de route
elle est respectueuse de la famille
politique auquel j'appartiens
respectueux ça veut dire on lui donne sa
chance jusqu'au bout
mais après la fac parce que nous sommes
de sociétés de gouvernements nous jouons
pas la politique de la terre brûlée
donc nous devrons prendre en
considération comment les choses
évoluent dans l'opinion
voilà étape après étape merci stéphanie
mais kms de public sénat arrive
maintenant pour la troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bon sens
julien dray le ps est-il toujours
l'avenir de la gauche
je l'espère j'en ai pas la certitude
pour être honnête je n'ai pas la
certitude parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
est aujourd'hui en péril
il est tiraillé par des forces
extérieures il est il est aussi tiraillé
par des forces à l'intérieur donc à une
situation périlleuse
cette situation périlleuse n'amène pas
la disparition de ce qu'est la pensée
progressiste et la pensée socialiste ce
qui est aujourd'hui menacé
c'est la forme organisationnelle dans
laquelle nous avons évolué depuis une
trentaine d'années qui menace le parti
socialiste le plus en tout cas pour vous
aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est emmanuel macron est-ce
que c'est jean luc mélenchon non c'est
pas c'est pas les forcer quand vous êtes
menacé vous pouvez toujours rejeté
respecter sur les forces extérieures
la vraie question c'est pourquoi ces
deux ces deux pôles se sont constitués à
l'extérieur du parti socialiste et ça
veut dire que nous n'avons pas été
capables sur la décennie qui viennent de
s'écouler de redonner un sens à nos
débats qui dépasse simplement les
possibles positionnement tactique les
cas le carriérisme des uns ou des autres
et de redonner un sens au débat
idéologique et alors c'est lui qui fait
un carton en ce moment on le voit un
lors de chacun de ses meetings c'est
emmanuel macron et hier en bretagne et
puis ce week-end à lille
alors oui je suis pas là il ya une
explication dans votre bluff
non non j'ai souri parce que quand
emmanuel macron que j'ai connu quand il
est devenu secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée ne le connaissez pas avant et
que nous sommes devenus des
correspondants de la nuit d'hier et
puisqu'on parlait beaucoup comme il
travaille énormément
souvent la nuit parce que il y avait
deux jours aujourd'hui ils étaient 1 oct
ambühl aujourd'hui encore il ay la
campagne c'est respectable parce que
bailleur moi je suis pas dans
l'excommunication
je crois que j'ai été le seul
responsable socialiste à être
extrêmement dur à l'égard d' emmanuel
macron dont il a quitté le gouvernement
les autres y lisait beaucoup de choses à
l'extérieur dans les couloirs mais ils
ont pas osé faire ce que moi j'ai du
ferraillage et dit qu'ils faisaient une
faute et que je ne m'étais pas cette
faute et que il m'avait dit une phrase
qui m'avait beaucoup marqué et la
confiance l'afer de l'autre etc sur
cette affaire-là
il avait pour moi ont pu une certaine
confiance mais je ne vais pas excommunié
je n'ai pas dit que c'est un trade je
n'ai pas juste un renégat je pense un
garçon de qualité
ces regards aujourd'hui je regarde
fait et je me garderai bien de commencer
là comme je l'entends parfois des
qualificatifs le représentant de la
banque
il a occupé l'espace politique et
l'interrogation qu'on doit avoir nous
c'est comment il a réussi à occuper cet
espace politique
et quand j'entends qu'il écume cet
espace musique simplement parce qu'il
est le cas le candidat des médias qui
est sponsorisé par les médias je trouve
cette explication trop simple c'étaient
les explications pas une bulle alors
c'est une expression je ne peux pas se
prononcer définitivement
mais par expérience ces mois de janvier
qui montrent si vous êtes une bible ou
non aux n'y est pas on est tous contre
le mois de janvier
pour moi la guerre l'instant la bulle
elle continue à vivre et même à
augmenter il augmentait jusqu'à où il
vit roulant j'ai un côté socialement
incontestablement 30 secondes
il est incontestablement la curiosité de
ce mois parce que tous ceux qui avaient
une certaine expérience politique se
disait il va commencer à se dégonfler
il attendait se dégonfle pas il ya du
monde donc c'est une interrogation
maintenant la question qui est posée
aussi pour emmanuel macron c'est que
abandonnait il va il est dans une
position qui est très équilibré mais
pour pouvoir être qualifié au deuxième
tour par exemple s'il voulait l'être
bien falloir qu'ils la vence sur des
propositions plus concrètes et notamment
qui a fait le voyage est donné à je lui
donne pas de conseils parce que je suis
pas son conseiller j'étais pas d'accord
avec vous correspondez encore je pars me
verrez avec les noms mais si vous voulez
comme est vraiment comme ça à la fois
être vraiment très très très lointain
une fois les 36 du mois d'ailleurs bon
parce que il ya eu quand même un passif
et qu'on s'est quand même disputé il
faut être honnête
à ce moment là
je me dis simplement si vous laissez
leur sens là que ma nostalgie forte
c'est que le travail qu'on avait essayé
de faire pour préparer cette campagne
présidentielle la place que devait
occuper c'est pas un secret emmanuel
macron montrait qu'on est quand même
assez vu a vu assez justes et que la
complémentarité avec je dirais une
capacité à s'ouvrir sur ce qui avait été
aussi la contestation sociale
gouvernement et emmanuel macron pour
françois hollande ni avec le rhin la
place a précisé la place qu'elle devait
occuper au rythme n'était pas un secret
c'est tout le monde allait conclure elle
va être essayé d'occuper une place très
importante dans cette campagne on
pouvait car comme une sous et je n'avais
pas de fonction qui avaient été définis
et simplement car il est le premier
ministre éventuellement je sais pas
danser que des ces termes là que que les
discussions avaient lieu
bon mais on voyait bien qu'il avait pris
une dimension qui étaient importantes et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il était
regardée avec une certaine tendresse
pendant tout un temps par le président
de la république bon maintenant il a
fait un autre choix qui correspond
d'ailleurs je regardais je réfléchissais
qui correspond à un différend
générationnelle sur le fond d'amendé
génération aujourd'hui non pas qu'ils
sont moins respectueuses de leurs aînés
mais qui sont dans le temps pressé et
donc vous pariez tailleur de génération
précédente la partie oui ils ont fait
partie aussi évident voilà on a des
générations qui considère que le le
devoir d' attendre par rapport aux
anciens mais vous l'avez avec vos
enfants aussi un jeu deviendrait au cas
où vous seriez capable de voter macro
élection présidentielle écoutez la ici
pour ce pour l'instant je suis pas dans
cette option c'est de la politique
fiction et après en plus je vais parce
que j'ai pas l'habitude de faire langue
de bois si je vous dis oui c'est dans
deux minutes j dépêche afp on va dire
voilà non dans 3 alors voilà et c'est
parti c'est une politique a pas
d'intérêt pour l'instant je suis
socialiste je suis dans la primaire de
la gauche
j'espère qu'elle va réussir j'espère que
le candidat qui sortira au roi de la
dynamite et si l'on exclut les chocs
dynamique je vous pose les jeux jour je
renverse la question que non la pause
mais faut la poser aussi les maillots de
mâcon si le candidat issu de la primaire
lui passe devant
il fait quoi oui on déposera la question
du programme et et si le candidat est
justement ça je lui dis en dessous il
doit qu'est ce qu'il doit faire je vous
en retirez renoncer maintenant je prends
peut pas discuter lorsqu'il faudra
analyser la situation
impopulaire
totalement ne bougerait pas le vote
utile contre françois fillon emmanuel
macron d'ores et déjà franchement
regardez les chais si je fais si je
m'engage je vous dis si je m'engage
maintenant dans une question qui n'est
pas encore dans auquel ne soit pas
capable de répondre des voiliers que de
coubertin se présente à lui et ce alors
c'est comme si vous commencez par dans
un repas vous commencé par le dessert
non d'arriver au caire pour manger moi
ce soir on va parler de jean luc
mélenchon parce que lui aussi menace le
parti socialiste lui aussi a le vent en
poupe dans les sondages
on les écoute toujours acerbe jean luc
mélenchon le rappelle que cette primaire
ni par la primaire de la gauche mais
celle du ps et du prg et que
deuxièmement elle sert à désigner le
perdant nous avons gelé dit d'une phrase
qui se veut résumer qui résume bien ma
pensée sur le sujet ils feraient mieux
de présenter des excuses plutôt que des
candidats je suis vous le connaissez
bien mais j'ai eu la question peut se
retourner à jean luc mélenchon est ce
que quand elle était ministre du
gouvernement de lionel jospin et qu'il
n'avait rien vu de ce qui se préparait
alors que j'étais son compagnon de
combat et que nous étions un certain
nombre à lui dire attention il a
présenté des excuses après après 2002 il
devrait revenir aujourd'hui voilà donc
je suis on commence des excuses au nom
de quoi
c'est parce que les candidats que c'est
lui qui a raison et il la question se
pose poser autrement si c'était
comporter autrement si en 2012
il avait participé à la majorité
présidentielle
non pas en passant sous la table non pas
en abandonnant son identité mais en
étant une opposition constructive et en
dix ans sur un certain nombre de
questions j'essaye de peser sur le cours
des événements
je ne vais pas l'affrontement tout de
suite parce qu'elle avait du possible de
gagner je pense par exemple que sur la
loi travail
si au lieu d'arriver tout de suite un
blocage on avait discuté on aurait ou
non se serait évité ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on a le droit et on aurait pu avoir
une loi par les lobbies responsabilité
dans l'effondrement n'a mais évidemment
puisque dès le départ avant même que ça
commence il avait planifié l'échec du
parti alice je vous donne un exemple
très simple j'ai dit et je le redis que
j'avais discuté avec lui au nom de
françois hollande la possibilité d'avoir
en 2012 un certain nombre de
parlementaires issus de sa sensibilité
qui serait soutenu par le parti liste il
a refusé
il a même refusé toute rencontre avec
françois blanc donc dès le départ ah bon
il a pris la responsabilité de françois
hollande qui a trahi la gauche
lui dit il a trahi la gauche dès le
départ ils n'ont ils pas trahi moi moi
je n'emploie pas le mot trahison jamais
il a pris une orientation politique et
qu'elle je n'étais pas d'accord mais
comme je jeûne excommunie pas je
n'exclus pas pas plus macron que
mélenchon étaient rares et quand la
gauche emploie des termes
d'excommunication elle commence des
guerres de chapelles qui la conduisent à
des scissions à des divisions et qui
conduit surtout à l'échec
et quand jean luc mélenchon lui
quelqu'un ou partie de la taille et que
l'autre c'est emmanuel macron vous
répondez quoi vous êtes au milieu
je lui réponds que comme ça a été un
trop triste quand il était jeune comme
moi il y avait une chose qu'on avait
pris appris c'est que la combat pour
l'unité
c'était un combat fondamental est que
les partisans de l'unité finissait
toujours par gagner donc avec mon fils
et noir dans l'amérique pas déclinantes
mais ça n'est pas erré soir dire qu'on
ne va pas dormir ce soir n'est pas dans
son sens les sectaires et ceux qui
divisent sont toujours pas regagné
abandonné l'ont gagné maintenant dans
des consignes circonstances tragiques
dans l'histoire mais la bataille pour
lutter c'est ça françois mitterrand
c'est en cela que kylie j'adorerais
avoir ce débat gelé fou je les lui d'un
certain point de vue avec un livre qui
là qu'il a traités de manière méprisante
mais le combat pour le rassemblement
pour l'unité il est constitutif de la
gauche il veut la mort de la gauche l'a
mordue par non résistantes ils parient
sur une logique et que je connais qu'est
la logique de l'effondrement et de
l'émergence d'une force politique
nouvelle
mais ça n'a marché nulle part nulle part
dans le monde
nulle pa et quand ça marche et en
général ça s'est terminée en catastrophe
plus importante
merci beaucoup un julien dray zamora est
avec nous aujourd'hui merci mais quelle
est la semaine prochaine c'est pierre
gattaz le président du medef
ça m'a changé il sera l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité ça va changer
effectivement dans la forme et le fond
bien sûr avec gtx
voilà merci à tous a très vite
i
[Musique]